حلقه النار منبع معظم الزلازل والبراكين
حول العالم يطلق عليها ايضا حافه النار او
الحزام الناريه وهي خط بحري مرسوم على
معظم سواحل المحيط الهادئ خريطه على شكل
حدوه حصان تؤرق ثبات الكره الارضيه وتهدد
استقرارها وتخز سكانها ومبانيها وبسببها
يفقد الناس ارواحهم وممتلكاتهم ويحاصروا
الالاف اسفل انقاض منازلهم
هيئه المسح الجيولوجي في العالم عينها على
هذا الحزام برصد كل ما يطرا عليه من تغير
لحظه بلحظه على مدار الساعه
يمتد هذا الحزام الناري على مسافه طولها
40 الف كيلو متر وعرضها 500 كيلومتر ويشمل
سواحل المحيط الهادئ لامريكا الجنوبيه
وامريكا الشماليه وبعض الجزر في غرب
المحيط الهادئ والعديد من الدول وهو موطن
لنحو 90% من زلازل العالم كما ان 80% من
اسوا الزلازل وقعت على امتداد هذا الحزام
الناري
لكن ما هو السبب العلمي خلف حلقه النار
وكيف تكونت حلقه النار تكونت نتيجه تحرك
الصفائح التكتونيه وهي عباره عن الواح او
طبقات ضخمه من القشره الارضيه تصطدم
ببعضها بتحدث نشاطا زلزاليا متكررا
كوارث هذا القوس الناري لا تقتصر على
الهزات الارضيه فقط بل هي منطقه خصبه
لمعظم براكين العالم فعلى طول امتداد
الحلقه توجد سلسله طويله من البراكين التي
يزيد عددها على 700 بركان الطبقات الضخمه
من الصفائح التكتونيه التي تشكل سطح الارض
تتحرك باستمرار على قاع ساخن منصهر هذه
الطبقات تنزلق بعضها اسفل بعض عندما
تتصادم فينتج عنها انفجار الحمم البركانيه
وصعودها الى سطح الارض نتيجه دفاع
والحراره من باطن الارض ما يسبب ثوران
البراكين
بيئه البراكين الواقعه على خط القوس
الناري منها البراكين المنقرضه التي لم
يرصد ثورانها منذ عشرات الاف السنين
والنائمه اي الخامله بشكل مؤقت اضافه الى
البراكين النشطه التي يندفع منها الغاز او
الحمم البركانيه بانتظام
اندونيسيا والفلبين واليابان من ابرز
الدول التي تقع على امتدادها هذا الطوق
وسبق ان شهدت جميعها بعض اسوا الزلازل في
التاريخ لكن هذا لا يعني ان وقوع الزلازل
والبراكين يقتصر على مناطق حلقه النار رغم
انها الاكثر عرضه للخطر
[موسيقى]